take that hey guys it's Thursday huh
it's grace and I don't remember what
we're calling this day but it's just a
day of Education well one day we'll have
a Thursday dedicated to learning how to
name Thursday
I would only tell me one ask you guys
what did you want to learn how to do
today and someone said how to tell a guy
that I don't want to go out with him but
nicely tomorrow is Valentine's Day oh
and you might be getting asked out on
dates by people that you don't
necessarily want to go on the date with
and/or don't feel attracted to them in
some way and it's always very awkward
and strange and you don't want to make
the person feel bad because they put
themselves out there and made themselves
vulnerable by asking you in the first
place so I've come up with 25 things
that you can say to avoid saying yes to
the date but in a relatively nice and or
non mean ish way something something
something flappy bird thank you so much
but I am not actually a woman or lady
word girl or female
to get what I mean that is so sweet
sometimes I think I have cats for feet
they don't like cats in it Chili's
teleporting actually I don't have a
phone right now or a computer or shelter
I'm homeless you don't want this will
you go on a date with me me my buddy
over there I get her and my out of the
frame I'm married I'm divorced and
widowed I'm a raccoon that got turned
into a human I eat trash
I'm not dating until it's legal for
everyone to get married I'm super
surface Lea political I scream when I
eat I'm engaged to Jesus he's right over
there the Cinnabon Jesus comes AI to
this guy I'll go get him Jordan I'm
allergic
no follow-up questions please I'm
expecting you to be sad when I tell you
that I don't think that's a good idea
am i period four weeks a month did I
just fart I'm gonna go take care of this
and we're stuck
I'm sorry I'm peeing in my pants to make
you feel like the better person in this
situation I only date other guys sure
okay
um I am free February 28 I have cancer
as my astrological sign and it really
says that I should stay away from dating
this month I have a lot of work I'm
sorry
warts I'm sorry worst wish to share have
a lot of it my nameday go fix that at my
house by myself
only through pre-order camp Takota calm
well there you go there are 25 things
you can say if someone that you don't
necessarily want to go on a date with
xu1 today to deflect the situation
guys get the Cardo comes out tomorrow
don't forget to pre-order please camp
Takota calm it's gonna be so exciting
anything it comes out at 9 a.m. Eastern
Standard Time tomorrow morning
now I thought I was being first I could